it's the destiny of the human race
expressed in numbers and it's the reason
the Empire will take us
I don't like the future
I predict which is what if you've read
Isaac asimov's Foundation books watch my
intro videos or read any of the press
about the TV show then you know the
story spans a long period of time if not
there's a monologue from Gail dornick to
open the series that sets it up what's
interesting here is that it comes from
the perspective of the future she says
that one day she'll learn the name
salvor Hardin pober Malo and the mule as
she's talking viewers are introduced to
salvor the planet Terminus and the
Mysterious Vault that hovers above the
ground there we see some local kids try
to approach it and get an explanation
from salvor who they refer to as the
warden that the vault is warning them to
stay away although it's implied that
she's not affected by the null field it
generates right off the bat you get the
idea that the story is going to be big
you're introduced to two timelines and
three planets in the first 10 minutes
the narration shifts from the future to
remembering the past and you meet Harry
Selden and his adopted son rached 35
years prior at the Imperial library on
the Empire's Capital Planet trantor
they're discussing Gail's arrival and
then we meet her on her Homeworld of
synax you see her looking at her prayer
stones that she removed before her
journey to Tran tour to meet Harry these
are cultural markers that every member
of the Sears church has in their cheeks
you get the feeling that her leaving has
set her apart from her people and later
learned that Math and Science go against
their beliefs as you learn more about
her background you find out that the
waters are rising on synax threatening
their way of life and the people have
turned to Faith for answers this led to
the universities being burned down and a
purge of intellectuals Gail taught
herself math hoping to help save her
people she won a contest by solving a
problem called the Abraxas conjecture
which no one had been able to figure out
for over 500 years years after that she
gets offered a job by Harry Selden and
says goodbye to her parents before
leaving synax for good she gets
transported to a jump ship which is our
introduction to the hyperspatial travel
that made it possible for humans to
settle on habitable planets throughout
the Galaxy she meets a man named Gerald
just before they're put to sleep for the
jump he turns out to be an agent of the
Empire that was sent to spy on her he
tells her they have to be put to sleep
because sometimes it can feel like your
mind and body are taking different trips
they have to be secured in these pods
because the artificial gravity has to be
turned off so they can navigate the jump
for some reason Gail wakes up while
they're in transit which is strange and
she's immediately Sedated by one of the
spacers working on the ship if you're
curious as to what these spacers are
I'll come back to them after the recap
when she arrives on tranthors he takes
the star Bridge down to the planet and
there's a lot of World building in the
details while she's is on her way to
meet Rach who takes her to Harry you
learn that billions of people live below
the surface on 100 Subterranean levels
where they never see the Sun or the
stars trantor is an ecumenopolist the
entire planet is encompassed by the city
as the surface became completely
developed they started to build down and
then they do things like projecting
Skies overhead on the lower levels to
make it look more natural
Harry asked her some questions about how
she solved the problem in an effort to
get to know her and then he drops it on
her that they're going to be arrested
tomorrow when she asks why he questions
if she's familiar with his work on
psycho history he says it's the destiny
of the human race expressed in numbers
when she hears this she asks if they're
worried that he can predict the future
and he says that they're worried that
people believe he can and they don't
like the future he predicts he tells her
that trantor is going to be destroyed
and the Empire will fall when he shows
her the prime radiant which is the
visual representation of his equations
she realizes that they believe she's the
only one that can prove him wrong Harry
agrees that that's true if he was wrong
she would be able to prove it but he's
not this is all bad news for her she
left home where she would have been
arrested only to find out she'll face
the same thing on trantor on the way out
she asked rates to take her to a Seer
church and the priest knows who she is
and he isn't a fan of selden's
prophecies either
you also meet the genetic dynasty of
dawn day and dusk they're all clones of
Emperor Cleon the first who have been
ruling for four centuries you see that
they do consider Selden as a threat and
also that they can be cruel when day
kills a man who's been working for him
for over 60 years just for being in
possession of something that Harry wrote
The Three versions of the same person at
three different ages have complete
control of the Empire day sits on the
middle thrown as the leader until dawn
grows old enough to take his place dusk
advises his younger selves and the cycle
continues Edo demersell is their first
Minister and appears to assist in
managing everything on top of going
after Harry and Gail the cleons are
dealing with the dispute over resources
between two planets that hate each other
anacrion and cespas because some agents
of the empire were killed in the dispute
they've been summoned to answer for that
and to try to avoid an all-out War Galen
Harry are arrested and their trial is
public regular citizens are able to
watch it with the cleons watching very
closely Harry explains that psycho
history is a predictive model designed
to forecast the behavior of very large
populations when questioned as to what
it says about the Empire he says it's
going to fall in 500 years or possibly
sooner they accuse him of trying to
undermine an Empire that's existed for
12 000 years and he pleads that he's not
a revolutionary it's just what the math
says he claims the collapse is too far
along it can't be stopped but they can
shorten the thirty thousand years of
barbarism that's going to follow it they
can cut that to just 1 000 years he
can't prove any of this his predictions
can't be checked because no one really
understands the math except for Gail so
after the first day of questioning
Gerald comes back and gives gal the
prime radiant he tells her that she has
has to disavow Harry and say that his
math is wrong and if for some reason the
equations turn out to be correct the
Empire will deal with that they'll fix
the problems without terrifying
trillions of people he gives her an
ultimatum either she says that Harry's
wrong and he dies and if she doesn't she
dies when she takes the prime radiant
back to her room she's able to activate
it and see the equations in court the
next day Harry is asked directly how he
would shorten the period of chaos his
plan is to create an encyclopedia
Galactica essentially collect all of
Mankind's knowledge and then print it
and distribute it after the fall a new
Empire Will Rise From the Ashes and this
will serve as the foundation of
knowledge for them to build upon when
they call Gail to testify she goes
against the empire verifying that
selden's math is correct and she
confirms that the Empire is dying as
they're leaving the courtroom she senses
that something's wrong with the star
garbridge and tells Harry about it then
it cuts to two simultaneous suicide
bomber attacks on the bridge and the
platform you see it kill everyone there
as it falls out of orbit to wrap around
the planet tearing 50 levels down
there's a hundred million people dead
and there's a fear that the outer
reaches may be in Rebellion
rage gives Gail a chance to give Harry
up but she refuses and they're taken in
front of the emperor Harry's work has
convinced him that things are going to
get worse so the starbridge attack isn't
a surprise he doesn't say that he
predicted that that would happen
specifically but it sounds like he knew
something would and he explains he can't
figure out who did it because he can't
predict individual's actions and then
when asked if the fall can be slowed
down he says yes they need to end the
genetic Dynasty thus gets angry about
that saying that the dynasty stopped the
wars Harry stands by he says that change
will help things but there's no movement
on either side when they ask why they
shouldn't just kill Harry gal steps in
and says that it would actually speed
things up that she saw that when she
looked at the equations she says that
Harry's hope and if they kill hope then
the people will kill them when they're
alone together Gail realizes the contest
was set up to find someone that could
understand selden's equations he just
reached out and got to her before they
did they're brought back in and told
that the decision is to let them
continue their work on psycho history
but not on trantor they're being allowed
to travel by slow ship to an uninhabited
planet called Terminus which of course
we saw at the beginning without a jump
ship the trip will take them years
they've been exiled and if psycho
history turns out to be fraudulent then
the foundation will just be allowed to
wither and if it's useful the Empire can
just co-opt it for themselves Terminus
is on the periphery and it neighbors the
two kingdoms that are apparently behind
the starbridge attack on the way out
Gail begins to realize that Exile was
always Harry's plan he says the planet
is perfect for what they need to do and
that's the twist is that even though he
was gambling to a certain extent on
these things everything had been planned
in advance and it did work out how he
expected he tells her you came here to
save your world why not think bigger
save the Galaxy and then it cuts the
Terminus 35 years later the narration
picks back up saying no one could
approach the Vault except for an outlier
like salvor Hardin Gail says she always
wondered if when Harry was formulating
the plan did he realize the Galaxy's
fate would rest on what she found inside
she thinks he did and thinks that's what
he feared the most
the Believers who threw their lot in
with an eccentric that pinned the fate
of the Galaxy on the back of a theorem
so abstract
well
it might as well have been a prayer in
the beginning of episode 2 the Cleon
still can't figure out who contracted
the people who were responsible for the
starbridge attack damersel's looking
into it she goes to a biohacking place
at one point and without anything else
to go on brother day still just kind of
wants to kill Harry but demarzel won't
let it happen because she knows there's
nothing to connect him to the crime both
anacrion and thespus deny being involved
and that seems like they're probably
telling the truth they hate each other
so it doesn't really make sense for them
to collaborate on the attack we see that
dusk is getting old and we see that
there's a natural tension that exists
between him and day we can imagine that
this probably always happens and he goes
to see the sea or priest at the church
that Gail went to where he sees the
destruction of what happened firsthand
he's trying to find out if Gail is a
Seer based on the weird stuff we've seen
around her it's an interesting question
while they're there demerzel gets hit by
a a Falling Rock and then later we see
brother dawn watching as she repairs
herself and that she's revealed to be a
robot and you may have noticed that
there aren't any real robots around in
trantor as it is brother dawn says that
all of her kind had died and she
corrects him saying they didn't die they
were destroyed by his kind so she does
her best to act like a human and at this
point it's not really clear how well her
true identity is covered up after
talking to the anacrion and the thespian
they have in their custody thus decides
that Mercy is the right way to go
brother day doesn't listen and decides
to make an example of the outer worlds
he sends ships to attack the planet and
then executes the members of the
delegation who came to trantor but
leaves the two leaders alive to go back
and tell their people how they failed
there's a teaching moment here for
brother dawn Demers L tells him it won't
always be like this when he asks exactly
how often do they choose to do things
like this she just says you always do on
the slow ship Galen Rachel started a
relationship that's getting serious and
you learn that there's four months and
four years left of the trip you see that
everyone's getting prepared to live
they're learning new skills you meet
some of the new characters that would
still be around in salvor's Timeline if
nothing else the colonists looks serious
they believe that the Empire is going to
fall and what they're doing is going to
be very important with the foundation to
preserve knowledge and rebuild the
civilization there's a Side Story here
about a pregnancy that Gail's involved
in it appears that women who get
pregnant opt to preserve that until
after they make it to terminus so it
makes you wonder if Rach and Gail won't
be the parents of somebody who turns out
to be important and I guess it should be
noted that salvor Hardin isn't born yet
we do see the two characters here that
are cast to play her parents when
they're much younger than what they'll
be in that timeline but otherwise I
don't see how this pregnancy thing is
really essential if it's not going to
pay off later either way way they're
trying to hide their relationship from
Harry and in his interactions you can
see that he realizes that the foundation
is going to be successful at least the
plan is fully in motion but that his
time with it is coming to an end the
calculations show that it's going to be
a tough road for the people who are left
behind something like a mortality rate
of 34.2 percent after five years on
Terminus although he says this is
trending downwards so their training is
working in their conversation there's
also a mention of the robot wars and the
hanging of AI sympathizers in an orchard
in the Imperial Gardens this all refers
back to what Denver Zell was telling
brother dawn about her kind being
destroyed by humans the episode comes to
an end as Gales following her normal
routine she's in the pool swimming and
then she gets a feeling that something's
wrong and decides to leave she goes
looking for rates and can't find him and
that leads her to Harry's room where she
sees Rach stabbing him and taking his
life we also also see that rates take
something from behind his ear before he
goes after her and then he puts her in a
pod throwing his knife inside telling
her that he loves her and then he
launches it the pot seems to be
programmed and it looks like she's
probably being put to sleep for a period
of time it's definitely not clear if her
interrupting what happened in Harry's
room is why she's on the Pod as all of
her interactions with Harry earlier made
it seem like he was grooming her to be
the leader on Terminus he even sent her
to that meeting to sit in in his place
it's definitely possible that she
interrupted because of that feeling she
had and then rates had to change his
plan which we're gonna have to wait and
see what was really going on with that
because all of his interactions with
Harry portrayed them having a close and
loving relationship there was the
awkward interaction at dinner we hadn't
seen anything like that between them
before everything we'd seen from Rach
was that he was concerned even though he
might not not have been a hundred
percent positive that Harry was right
and there definitely are seeds planted
there where it could go the other way
Gail telling him that the math wasn't
complete and it's a pretty good
Cliffhanger when you think about it like
that so I'm excited to see where it goes
in the next episode so to wrap it all up
Harry used psycho history to forecast
the fall of the Empire he believes what
the math is telling him and knows that
the cleons will never give up their
power willingly by solving Abraxas when
no one else could Gail is considered the
best person to check if his work is
correct she gets pulled into the
situation she decides to go against the
empire and this all leads to all these
people on the slow ship being exiled to
terminus to create the foundation
there's quite a few Mysteries to think
about first and foremost who's really
behind the attack on the star Bridge it
definitely doesn't seem like the people
that are being punished are the ones who
did it which means there could be
blowback from that but also so that
there could be another force in play
Gail has plenty of mysteries around her
too this idea that she senses things why
did she wake up during the jump where
did she go at the end is she hibernating
and for how long what was the
significance of the zygote scene is part
of the reason that they gender swap this
character because she's going to have
Descendants on Terminus why did Rach
kill Harry that feels like it was part
of the plan rather than some murderous
rage but then how did Gail walking in
change things what was the device he
took from behind Harry's ear what's
going on with the Vault how did it get
there because it seems beyond Harry's
natural skill set although he did have a
lot of people working for him and what's
going on with the cleons having a robot
they kept dumberzel mostly in the
background in these two episodes but
even if you don't know anything about
the books I'm sure she's starting to
pique your interest we can still revisit
the idea of marriage in an air damn
Brothers
there are things you will know
we'll never I may someday no death
episode 2 ended on a big turn with Rach
killing Harry Selden and sending Gail
into space on an escape pod a little
later in this episode we get a
confirmation from Hugo that people do go
into hibernation or cryosleep and I
assume that's there to let us know what
happened to Gail episode 3 opened with
another turn in that it opted not to
provide the resolution or aftermath of
the event on the ship and instead
decided to jump around on the timeline
the episode opens with another voice
over narration from Gail talking about
ghosts the empires and more specifically
the Palace of the Empire's ghost is
Cleon the first we go back in time 400
years to the end of his Reign and see
him planning with them Brazil for what
comes after his death this makes her
role more explicit you see that she was
there to plan it that she was involved
in setting up the Clone program and the
transition and that kind of implies that
she was actually running the empire for
a period of time since she says that the
first Brother Don they put on the throne
was still a baby there's an emphasis on
loyalty here her loyalty to the Empire
to cleon's Dynasty and the question of
if the Empire will be loyal to her so
far we're only working with vague
references to what's going on with
robots in the TV show which means all of
this is still a mystery from there we
jump to 19 years after the starbridge
bombing it's the strange time in the
cycle where Lee Pace is playing Brother
Don that doesn't last for long though
because it's brother dusk's last day
before becoming brother Darkness or the
end of his life which they refer to as
his Ascension this is the version of
dusk who was in favor of Mercy for
anachreon and cespas and he's still
thinking about that and what Harry
Selden said now that he's reaching the
end as a final present they all go up to
destroy what's left of the star bridge
in orbit as they're looking at it for
the last time Dawn and day promised to
make something thing better in cleon's
honor for the outgoing dusk we see that
the work was ongoing when the original
Cleon died it then became a very visible
reminder of his legacy on trantor and
then of course it fell during the attack
demrazel has been there from its
beginning to its end and she almost
looks emotional here and dusk asked her
about it later in this odd exchange
where he questions her love for him and
her feelings for the original Cleon she
tells them that he's enough but after he
closes his eyes she continues saying
it's just that you always leave me in
the morning he goes to his Ascension
brother dawn becomes the new brother day
having grown into their greatness the
new dawn is presented as the old dusk is
ready to incinerate himself and
something about that situation starts to
feel wrong to him there may be something
to this because he's experienced this
same ceremony in the past but before we
find out demarzel grabs his arm starts
to sing to him and then encourages him
on his way to meet his end from there
the story jumps forward another 17 years
where we meet the 14th Edition of Cleon
who was the baby that was crying at the
ceremony as he's becoming a young man
after that we transitioned to see the
colonists arrive on Terminus because
everything about their Landing is
planned out they're surprised to find
the Vault when they get there as they
approach it they experience the null
field and everyone gets knocked out they
Scuttle the slow ship they crashed it on
the surface and then they build up the
colony there's a brief scene of salver
when she's younger her parents are
talking about her being a dreamer or a
thinker and she seems to be fascinated
by The Vault we fast forward to where
she's grown and watch her do an
experiment where she discovers that the
null field is expanding it's getting
bigger in her role as the warden we see
that she's working on this fence this
sort of generated field that protects
their colony and we also see the
encyclopedists working to preserve
knowledge to follow through on hair his
plan
solver takes her mother to the Vault to
show her that the null field is growing
and they talk about her connection to it
how her mother found her underneath it
as a child at the time her parents kept
this a secret because they didn't want
her to be treated differently we learned
that Salva was drawn to it she thought
it was calling to her and then when she
was underneath it she couldn't
understand why it was hurting her mother
when asked if she can hear it now if
it's calling her she just says that she
thinks it's waking up so even though
they kept it a secret it's mentioned
that she's still an outsider and we see
that she doesn't really mix with the
other colonists and to that her mom
reminds her that she's always been
special her boyfriend Hugo who's a
traitor arrives he's got a 29 hour stop
on the planet we see some of their
romance some of their life how that
works and after they have sex she has a
feeling which gets her out of bed and
she leaves to check the perimeter she
ends up seeing or more likely imagining
a child running into The Old Ship she's
never able to catch up with it and to
get a good look but as viewers we can
see that he has what looks like Rachel's
knife in his hand he disappears after
she follows him inside and she just
finds one of those Bishop claw creatures
that are native to the planet there and
when she scares it away she notices
something in the sky above the planet
her and Hugo check it out through her
telescope and they realize that a
necrion ships have shown up this is the
first time anyone's come to the planet
in 30 years she takes this information
to the encyclopedists who don't really
think it's a big deal as far as they're
concerned they're a part of the Empire
they're protected by the emperor and all
they need to do is just call them let
them know what's happening and they'll
intervene because of course this is a
necrion when they attempt to make
contact they realize that the comms buoy
isn't working they look for rational
reasons that this might be happening
things unrelated to what's going on with
the ships above their Planet but salvor
is not convinced she starts taking stock
of the weapon in preparing for the worst
thinking that they just went by the buoy
so they probably destroyed it on their
way and we see the division here she's
considered an outlier they actually call
her that and basically dismiss anything
that she says they realize they have
about 40 hours until they arrive in an
act of desperation salver's mom pulls
out the prime radiant which she
collected from Harry's room after he was
killed just to see if maybe salvor will
connect with it salver had never seen it
doesn't know anything about it and her
mom asked her to take a look at it
because if she was part of the plan it
would make it a lot easier to believe in
it she seems fascinated but there
doesn't seem to be anything that she can
do you see the equations swirl around
and then sort of fall but it's not clear
if she had any effect on that at all and
before they leave she makes the
distinction that different is not the
same as special as they're waiting for
the ships to get there she has another
feeling she ends up chasing the vision
of the young rage again but this time
she finds the creature and notices it's
been shot by an arrow she finds herself
surrounded with what looks like a group
of Warriors saying that anacrions are
not allowed on Imperial soil what are
you doing here and the episode ends
there
all cleons
are perfect genetic copies of the first
we don't have souls
so
this Lima woman is saying we're what
not human the episode opens with teenage
brother dawn remember this was the baby
who was presented at the Ascension
ceremony timeline wise he was born 19
years after the starbridge bombing and
then there was another 17-year time Jump
so we're 36 years on from Harry selden's
trial to sync things up with Terminus it
took the colonists roughly five years to
get there and now they've been settled
for 30 more there's a bit of narration
here with Gail reinforcing the idea that
psycho history only predicts the
movement of masses and not individuals
and it all tends to reinforce the idea
that this particular clone of Cleon is
different in some way which could
probably cause a problem for a
predictive model that's supposed that
the emperor would always stay the same
regardless of that there seems to be
something wrong with them he climbs out
on his balcony and with a painful look
on his face throws himself off the edge
there's a young Gardener there working
who witnesses his fall as his protective
Aura device saves him from becoming a
blood stain what he was trying to
accomplish isn't exactly clear the young
Gardener gets scared and runs away that
leads to a side story where he looks
into her and ends up spying on her after
she gives him a tip about using a
medicinal plant called Wolf's breath her
name's Azula she's been working in the
garden since she was a teenager and it
seems like she might be important later
we check in with brother day who's with
the courtesan it gives us an insight
into how he experiences pleasure and
sexual satisfaction and a little bit
more about how their protective auras
work before he can satisfy his
physiological need for intimacy
demersell interrupts because the Proxima
opal is passed this is the leader of a
religious space and it sounds like a
powerful one considering it has
trillions of followers there's a
potential problem here because there's a
new candidate who has a chance to take
over that follows something called the
primary Octavia this is a pre-imperial
belief that centers around individuated
sentience long story short as clones the
cleons could be viewed as less than
human brother day explains it to Dawn he
says if the Galaxy comes to believe that
their leaders are less than rather than
more than they may cease to follow so
there could be a legitimate threat to
their power and brother dusk plans to
visit the conclave in person to address
the situation even though all this time
has passed since the starbridge attack
on tranthor they're still unrest and we
see there's an uprising in the lower
levels from the heatsink workers and the
cleons also learn about a Communications
buoy going offline in the outer Reach
This prompts brother day to bring up
Terminus in the Exile of Harry selden's
followers there they have problems with
the conclave there's unrest at home and
now there's problems in the outer reach
he asks his brothers if they're starting
to see a pattern forming Harry Selden
laid out these very problem that they're
facing now and at that time brother day
didn't do anything about it because he
saw him as a charlatan so there's a rift
forming between day and dusk the odor
has a reason to stick to what he did
back in the past even in light of all
these new events starting to look like
Harry's predictions are coming true
the current brother day summons the
royal master statisticians to ask them
about what they've learned about Harry
selden's math they've been working on it
for three decades now and still don't
really understand it they believe the
predictive models are counterfactual
because since he made his predictions
the Empire has expanded rather than
contracted in every meaningful metric
when pressed though they can't say that
there's a non-zero chance that he isn't
right about everything and frustration
day goes and calls out dust for his past
mistakes but the necrion thespace and
Terminus he says he's not going to let
him make the same mistakes and says that
he'll go to the conclave instead
demarzel steps up and interjects that
the primary Cleon has never left trantor
at any time in the genetic Dynasty but
she isn't able to change his mind so
dusk throws it out there that his
brother is haunted by selden's Ghost and
then he sent back to trantor where he
summoned someone to go investigate the
boy going dark in the outer reaches and
he tells him that the dispatches from
the foundation have become sporadic pay
them a visit and tell them the Empire
won't be kept in the dark so they'll be
heading to terminus we visit there and
pick up with salvor who ran into those
anacrions in the remains of the slow
ship they've been on the planet for a
while scouting and their story is that
they're looking for the navigation
module from the ship they get salvor to
take the leader through the fence
because she wants to go to the tower in
the center of the city it works out that
she's only able to get the one person
through so the others tell her if she
doesn't return in the time a watch is
passed they'll raise the city to the
ground on the way salver has another
vision and makes a move towards the
Vault where the null field knocks her
captor out she takes her prisoner and
figures out that she's the grand
Huntress which gives them leverage they
can't really decide what to do with her
and salver thinks they need to get ready
to defend themselves she tries to get
information out of pharah because she
leaves the navigation module is just a
distraction she shows her that she can
predict the outcome of coin flips to
sort of Psych her out and through the
scars she has and her fake eye puts it
together that she must have been five or
six when she survived the Empire's
attacks on her Planet salvor realizes
where her resentment against the empire
comes from it's from losing her mother
and her brother and she tells the others
that she senses a deadness inside her
that she wants everyone to die salvor
talks to the encyclopedist Louis perine
and you get a better understanding of
why he disregarded her in the last
episode this idea he has of her being an
outlier comes from the connection to the
bolt which he says is something that
couldn't have been predicted through
psycho history after all it can't
account for individuals he goes to talk
to pharah who mostly ignores him and
this insistence he has that they're
backed up by the Empire she says all of
them have been exiled and they're all
dying just the different speeds and she
points out that Harry prophesies that
the fall would begin at the edge of the
Galaxy and their conversation it starts
to become clear that they destroyed the
buoy and landed on Terminus to get a
response from the Empire they're just
trying to provoke them but it isn't
clear what they're after or why they
think they have a chance against them
the people on Terminus start to realize
that there's a lot of anachron
surrounding the city and when salver
goes outside she has a different kind of
vision this one's pretty vivid she's in
the Imperial library and almost looks
like Gail at least the clothes she's
wearing and she sees the boy with
Rachel's knife again she's able to talk
to him this time and says I won't hurt
you just tell me who you are and there
is no answer and all of that starts to
convince her that it's coming from the
Vault she tells Hugo this he says that
she's special and that he has absolute
faith in her
Ferris starts to convince Lewis to help
her by telling him that they are
technologically bankrupt ever since
their atmosphere was set on fire she
continues the story that they need the
navigation module because they have
ships but can't make their way to a
different system to rebuild their
civilization as salvos watching the
troops outside the fence assemble a
weapon she thinks there's a larger
strategy at play here but she can't
figure it out the vault is an anacrion
or alien at all she believes it's from
Harry but she has this crisis of faith
that maybe Lewis is right maybe her
being an outlier is the reason that
things are going wrong and maybe the
Visions are warning her to stay away
Hugo counters this by saying what if you
are selden's plan which I guess you
can't blame him for not understanding
how this works and picking up on the
fact that there is something going on
with salvor we leave them and in the
closing moments we see the cryopod
holding Gail moving through space and it
approaches what looks like a spacecraft
as it cuts to Black and the episode ends
there
what year is it
how long was I asleep
twelve thousand one hundred and two era
Imperial your cryo session duration was
34 years
223 days season 1 episode 5 opens with
Gail telling us about the stories that
scared her the most as a child they were
about black holes it was the idea of an
event horizon Venture into that and the
gravitational pull prevents you from
turning back Escape becomes impossible
and you could see the parallel of what's
going on with her after she made the
decision to try to solve the Abraxas
conjecture in flashback we go back to
see how that played out at one point
Gail was involved with the Seer Church
she was an acolyte and this seems to be
a point of Pride for her parents as her
community has turned to their faith in
light of this climate catastrophe that's
going on on their Planet the sea levels
Rising that's threatening their way of
life and we hear how it's getting more
and more difficult for her family to
make their living through the farming of
algae we already on understood this from
the first episode so the main thing here
is this connection she has with an old
family friend who's been labeled as a
heretic she finds him one night after
going to the university which is
supposed to be abandoned he's there
looking through the books and when she
tells him that he needs to leave because
the seers have condemned the building he
says that the books are heretical right
that all analytical learning goes
against the faith of the Awakening he
says the line here that we heard her say
to Rach that when a planet wants you
dead you die she tries to get him to
leave without the books and he offers
her the writing from Cali which is what
she'll end up using to solve the problem
that gets her to trantor the last thing
he tells her is the cleanse will pass
all things have a cycle the knowledge
helps to survive the destruction until
the rebirth arrives and you see Gail try
to reframe his statements to fit the
church's ideas that the floods are a
challenge from the sleeper that they
just have to endure and then eventually
it'll all get better he counters that
people did this we did this not the
slumbering God so this guy is the
localized version of Harry Selden right
he sees this collapse is coming that
can't be stopped by putting your faith
into this Church's system later we see
him being executed for being a heretic
as an acolyte Gale is there she has to
help prepare him for the ceremony and
the books are submerged with him his
final statement is that this will not
stop the Seas from rising and there's a
seed planted there so Gail goes back
alone later she swims down and recovers
Calais writing and even though she's
starting to rise up in the ranks of the
church she starts reading about math she
uses her new knowledge to solve the
abraxis conjecture and eventually she
enters the competition and gets the
message that she solved it and that
Harry Will validate her proof he tells
her that the Empire will be reaching out
but that he hopes that she'll come to
streamling university on trantor to meet
him which of course we've already seen
her do that we get a little bit more of
her parents being pissed her father
tells her he'd rather his daughter die
than go to the Machine World of trantor
but at this point knowing there's
nothing left on Sinex but destruction
she's past the point of no return and
decides to choose science over faith
hoping that she can find a way to save
her people through getting off the
planet and going to work with Harry
Selden
it cuts back to the present timeline and
we see her Escape pod being brought
inside this ship where she wakes up she
remembers Harry's deaths and notices
that she has rates's knife inside the
Pod that comes in handy when she can't
open the door the knife is pulled into
this slot and is basically the key and
as she goes inside we realize that the
ship's AI thinks that she's rage as it's
initiating things for his arrival she
finds out she's alone there and that the
ship won't give her access to some
functions because again she's not right
she's not the person the ship was
expecting she finds out that she was
asleep for nearly 35 years so what's
happening here is happening at the same
time as what's going on with salvor and
the encyclopedist on Terminus we see
them and it picks up right where they
left off salvor is looking at the large
weapon just outside the fence and the
fact that the anacrions are using a
cloaking device they're hiding it from
someone other than the people on
terminus confirms that their motive goes
beyond Terminus itself and right at that
moment the Imperial jump ship arrives
and now we know what's going on back at
Terminus City you see that the
encyclopedists are thrilled that they
actually came that the Empire is backing
them up but also that this is exactly
what Pharaoh was hoping would happen the
ship the Aegis makes contact and
essentially learned that they don't have
any military they talked to salvor who's
the warden and she explains that they
confess to destroying the communications
buoy and so he wants to talk to pharah
directly to see what she has to say
about that salvor thinks this is a
mistake but her Communications are
jammed before she can really say her
piece and then Lewis goes to get pharah
and bring her into the tower this sets
off red flags with the troops
surrounding the fence salvor doesn't
want pharah to go anywhere near the
tower and so she races to the city there
she realizes she's too late Lewis is
already taking pharah over to the the
tower and there she pulls out a field
disruptor that she hid in her fake
eyeball and when she detonates that that
shuts down the fence the inacrion
Warriors are then able to charge into
the City and you see that they are
killing some of the colonists the
Imperial ship sees what's happening on
the ground and starts to land while
salvor is looking for pharah who has
taken her mother hostage when she finds
her there's an intense standoff where
cyber won't drop her gun to save her
mother and after that works out they
have a crazy one-on-one fight where
salvar eventually gets the upper hand
but pharah's men are there they have her
mother again so it's essentially a
standoff later when they're looking over
the destruction pharah points out that
Terminus isn't innocent she says that
selden's predictions are what inflamed
the empire in the first place because of
what their Prophet said her whole world
burned and there is some truth to that I
guess from her perspective although
there is this ongoing mystery of who
actually blew up the star Bridge the
fighting continues on the ground people
are definitely dying we see Hugo get
shot and then as the Imperial ship
approaches we see that the inacrions
were assembling that weapon in order to
take out the ship and we see it come
down to the ground so we see what their
larger plan was although it's not clear
to me what the motivation behind it is
we're gonna have to wait and see because
they're not actually in a position to be
able to fight back if a full-blown
battle breaks out with the Empire it
feels like it has to be more specific to
that ship or this location but we don't
find out before the episode ends
back on the ship Gail can't get
authorized to do anything important like
send a message or guide the ship
somewhere different she is able to do a
search of the Imperial database though
and she learns that the slow ship did
make a determinous she looks into
Harry's death she finds out the official
story is that he was murdered by Rach
and she's listed as an accomplice and
per his own directive Harry was ejected
in a casket he designed himself and we
do see his body being sent out into
space She searches for rage and finds
footage of him being questioned by the
encyclopedist Louis Perrin is now in
charge after Harry's death Racha admits
that he murdered Harry and won't say
much about it other than implying that
he understands more about why things
happen the way they did than Lewis does
for his crime he is executed and we see
him get Space they throw him outside in
the vacuum without a suit before that
happens we see his final words he says I
know it's hard I know what I've done Sun
seems incomprehensible but you can never
lose faith in the plan ever you can
still solve a puzzle even with a piece
missing and it almost feels like he's
talking directly to Gail here knowing
that he put her on the Escape pod in his
place of course she breaks down after
watching this and there's a point where
she briefly contemplates suicide she
brings a scalpel into the shower
thinking about her time with Rach and
then before she can go through with it
the ship changes its course and that
flips her around it gives her a chance
to think and she decides to try to
figure out what's going on there's a
somewhat long sequence where she can't
find out where they're going the ship
won't tell her where they're going so
she uses the information she can get in
math to figure out what direction
they're going in then she can't see
outside because there's a view screen so
she goes and she finds a suit tethers
herself does a spacewalk she can't see
anything at first with the naked eye but
once she looks in infrared she realizes
they're heading towards a dark star with
that information Gail realizes that
their destination is Helicon Harry's
Homeworld which we don't have a lot of
background about in the show and as
she's figuring that out she starts to
see some strange things she sees what
looks like puddles of blood and then she
comes across a glitched out projection
of Harry where he looks like he did the
last time she saw him and the episode
ends there this is probably related to
the device we saw Rach removed from
behind his ear Harry is dead but now
it's apparent there was more to his plan
that would happen after that event
well you hunt like a man you consider
yourself a man now
I don't know I suppose only a man
can replace the man
the sixth episode opens with another
narration from the future from Gail
talking about trantor and the emperor
that would live forever the man who had
triumphed over death itself the leader
who never knew doubt in all his
lifetimes until he met Harry Selden on
his ship we see that the current brother
day Cleon the 13th if you're keeping
track was a little messed up from the
hyperspatial travel of the jump
considering the active ruler has never
left the planet since the genetic
Dynasty took over we could presume that
he probably hasn't experienced this
before unless it happened when he was
younger out of curiosity he asked
themersel what it's like to be awake
during the trip he mentions that the
spacers who are there watching over
humans as they travel or engineered for
it but he barely considers them human
this may turn out to be important later
but what stands out about it now is that
these spacers are something different
than what we know about from asimov's
other work demrazel tells him that when
space Folds the human mind can't
tolerate the discontinuity which makes
us wonder why Gales could whenever she
woke up during her first trip on a jump
ship there's another question of what
demersell was actually doing when he
walks in on her it looks like she's
repairing her face so does she have to
do routine maintenance when I first saw
it I thought maybe that's how she
prepares herself to go in front of
people but then later we find out that
she wasn't planning on leaving the ship
anyway in case you forgot she's a robot
as they approached their destination we
learn a lot about lumenism as they talk
it's fifteen thousand years old it
predates The Empire three trillion
people believe in this faith and they
wear crystals made of salt that come
from the Leviathan mines and they pray
by ritualistically touching it which is
something we've seen demrazel do in
previous episodes because yeah she does
actually believe in this religion
brother day doesn't understand it he
says that she has a purpose to serve him
and his brothers and in the Empire it's
actually built into her code and she
explains by saying that the search for
meaning is not always about the answer
it's also the process of seeking that
enlightens so the show is building up
its own lore here Zephyr Halima is
definitely a threat to the emperor's
power and we see that she has some pool
when she's the first person to welcome
him on his arrival the fact that she's
by herself that there's no big welcome
for the ruler of the entire galaxy takes
him out of his element this all looks
pretty great especially the ship coming
into the Salt Palace and it's all in
service to the premise that there's
going to be a new Proxima the previous
one died brother day meets with Zephyr
gallot who is the one that's on his side
she's in the lead to become the next
Proxima but the vote could go towards
Halima he tries to tip the scales by
pledging to have the Empire build a
moon-wide desalination plant so that
everyone there will have fresh water
which seems to solidify things for galat
until the rebirth ceremony for the
previous Proxima is interrupted by
Halima who just sort of walks in and
makes this crazy moving speech for
everyone there where she says that the
greatest crime against the mother is
stagnation which is basically saying
that the genetic Dynasty goes against
their faith the crowd is moved even
demersell bows with the others and that
leaves day as the odd man out it's not
as if they're in a frenzy against the
existence of the emperor but you can see
that she's opening the door and may be
charismatic enough to take them there
so while brother days in a struggle to
win the hearts and minds of the
followers of the Luminous faith brother
Don is struggling with how different he
is from those that came before him we
see this play out with the Zora The
Gardener who saw him jump from his
balcony and when brother dust takes him
hunting on his first time out he kills
twice as many as dusk's record which he
knows might be a problem so he takes
three of those and throws them in the
bushes and tries to make out like they
killed the exact same number brother
dusk tells him that only a man can
replace the man after their hunt and he
takes him to a brothel where we learn
that they sleep with women who have
their memories erased afterwards so they
don't have any recollection of what
happened he picks a woman that looks a
lot like Azora and then doesn't sleep
with her and we see that brother dusk
learns about this because he has her
brought to him before her memory is
white later we see Dawn invite Azora
into his room he wants to show her the
guard Garden from the ledge outside his
window when she's reluctant to come out
he takes off his protective Aura and
offers to let her put it on she declines
and we learn that he's colorblind and
this is a problem because he's different
from all the cleons that preceded him
and maybe this explains why he was so
good at hunting but it is one of his
biggest secrets and now she knows about
it in a gesture to earn his trust she
steps towards the edge and says if I
were trying to keep a secret I'd push me
off and instead of killing her on the
spot he decides to kiss her which is the
last that we see of these two then we
see his secret from the hunt get
discovered by the mysterious Shadow
master obrecht in my episode three and
four book to show video I mentioned how
this guy has shown up twice 35 years
apart and doesn't look like he's aged at
all and at the end of his scene here he
walks away and just sort of disappears
which I'm not sure what they were
actually going for there it adds to his
mystery and I hope we find out more
about what's going on with this
character in the next couple of episodes
on Terminus the anacrion troops are at
the crash site for the jump ship and we
find out that they're looking for Darwin
who their sure survived because the
Empire is as good at preserving their
people's lives as they are at taking the
lives of others back at Terminus City we
see the aftermath of the battle and we
see two of the kids from the first
episode who survived it does look like a
lot of people died in the attack salvor
is still out cold Farrah decides to keep
her alive because she thinks she's the
key to the vault which is a big unknown
at this point Doran is more important to
their plan and they need some
encyclopedists and she mentions that
they need to get going because the
Invictus won't wait forever the kids
were hiding they're eventually able to
rescue salvor who explains that the
Invictus was a ghost ship it was this
legendary imperial destroyer that
disappeared so this is the big plan the
anacrion thinks that if they can get a
hold of this Invictus it'll be their
Redemption and they need some of those
encyclopedists who have special skills
that can help them take it over as far
as we can guess they tell them they just
need their help and that they'll leave
Terminus after they get what they're
after at first the foundationers don't
want to help but a shot in the leg to
one of their loved ones gets the
cooperation that the anacrions need
Salva and the kids make it outside they
run into her dad and Hugo she wants to
go after the Corvettes and she believes
that it's possible that Harry put her
there to stop the first crisis based on
this intuition she's been having how
she's feeling drawn to do certain things
and the Vault waking up on their way
there her dad tells her about trantor
how things were actually pretty good at
least for his family but he says they
knew it was all built on lies and even
though he didn't really understand
Harry's predictions he did want to get
with her mother and she actually did
believe in the plan man so it's the
father and daughter moment which does
feel a little ominous as they approach
the ships
we see salvor Take the Lead even though
her dad wanted to go at first and as she
starts to put her plan in action she's
hit with a vision and is disabled right
there in the open on the ground and this
vision's even more Vivid than the
previous ones where she's in Gail's
clothes and we see that she's on the
slow ship we hear the conversation Harry
and Rach had before the murder Harry
explains that there's only one scenario
where you leave the ship and that's the
one that makes it impossible for you to
remain on board I don't take my life you
do rates is not into this at all he
tries to say that you can fix this and
Harry's pretty adamant he says
everything collapses because you stay
here with her referring to Gail and that
everything would be wasted he says that
the entire galaxy is pivoting on the
actions of an individual you they go
back and forth he asks them if he trusts
the math he says he hates the math he
asks him if he trusts him and he said he
wishes he never met him and he says that
the cryopod is programmed for you don't
stop to say goodbye to her and he does
go ahead and stab him like we saw and at
that moment salvor walks in as Gail did
and then in the present time Hugo wakes
her up and it ends there they are seen
and a shootout breaks out where they
have The High Ground and cover but her
father's out there on his own he's
trying to get to the ships with
explosives and he almost makes it as
sabor's picking off the soldiers but he
does get shot and then he ends up
sacrificing himself detonating the
explosive which takes out the Corvettes
but kills him in the process
later after they get away salvor has
another crisis of Faith she thinks that
everything that's going wrong is her
fault she tells Hugo what she heard
Harry say and again he thinks she's
special and she's resistant to the idea
but now that her father's dead she's
really motivated to get revenge against
pharah the episode comes to an end when
they try to sneak back to his ship
they're caught right away because what
else is pharah actually doing but
waiting after they destroyed the
Corvettes she orders her men to kill
salvor and Hugo transfers control of his
ship he slaves it to her so that they'll
need her alive and they need him also
because she doesn't know anything about
piloting a ship so Farah has everything
she needs and they load up and the
episode ends with them leaving the
planet
if this was really only about the past
psycho history laid out then you would
have let Cleon kill you in that throne
room
true
so why didn't you
I wanted to live we start off with the
Terminus storyline at the end of episode
6 Pharaoh had gathered up the people she
needed to go after the Invictus and we
pick up with them as they're approaching
it we get the story of some of the
abandoned Palladium mines that were
there where Hugo used to work without
the aid of the Empire's Tech after the
starbridge attack the industry just
broke down and when pharah accuses him
of abandoning his people he responds
that it was more like there was one less
thespian to fight over the scraps as
they approached the Invictus we get a
little bit of history at one time it was
the most powerful weapons platform in
the galaxy and it was indeed a world
killer it had disappeared 700 years ago
but it's been spotted throughout the
Galaxy since then never responding to
hails and never being seen in the same
place twice Commander Doran says that
because it's a jump ship and the Empire
considers that Tech estate secret they
would just as soon destroy it rather
than let the inacrions get it we find
out why they needed him why they
actually needed his body and it's
because of his Imperial Nanobots they're
there in his bloodstream they can Aid in
fast healing if he's injured and they
can also be used as identification and
they know that they're going to need
something like that because it still has
active defense systems they actually had
two ships destroyed when they tried to
approach it the first time so basically
they have to do a spacewalk in order to
not trip off the alarm system as they're
getting into their suits Commander Dolan
tells salvor and Hugo that he has a
built-in distress Beacon if they can get
access to some form of comms then
they'll be able to send out a distress
signal and the idea comes up that they
might be able to get access at one of
the abandoning mining stations so it's a
Big Ten Thousand meter jump they all
make it except for Hugo who says his
suit is malfunctioning as he floats past
the inner ring where everyone else has
just landed I'm not sure if he did this
on on purpose based on what they were
saying just before that but it
definitely didn't feel like this was
going to be his death like that was it
even though if it was a plan salvor
doesn't know that so she is actually
pretty broken up about what happened as
they're approaching the airlock they get
a little bit too close together and the
defenses kick in the ship starts
shooting at them Commander door one is
able to get the airlock open that shuts
down the defenses and as a reward ferric
kills him since he's already served his
purpose at this point they spend some
time exploring and we get some more
World building details at first the
environmental systems are off and they
get those turned back on and we see that
they use artificial gravity of some sort
they notice that in regular intervals
the lights are pulsing and Lewis thinks
it might be a countdown when he notices
that they're getting closer together and
we learned that the ship jumped to where
it is now randomly it just showed up
there one day and the current theory is
that it is continuing to jump It's
what's been happening to it the crew
must have lost control at some point and
that's why anacrion had to act fast
because they expect it to jump out again
so you need to figure out what's going
on before that happens and it disappears
forever and when they examine the
countdown they realize they have about
four hours until it happens at one point
they encounter an energy barrier and
salvor is able to disable that because
she worked on the fence which is a newer
form of the same kind of technology and
figuring that out means that now they
need her because they're probably going
to run into more of these and so when
they try to overtake the anacrions when
they try to rebel and get their weapons
which doesn't work out she gets to live
and with that story that's pretty much
where things are left
on the emperor's ship outside of the
Salt Palace we see that brother days in
a pretty bad mood after halima's speech
demersell explains to him that if she
hadn't knelt it would have been a clear
contradiction of her faith and they have
an argument about where her loyalties
lie he points out here that her being a
robot is a secret he says I wonder what
Halima would say if she were made aware
that demersel can't be reincarnated
either and he says that her actions were
a betrayal a betrayal of her directive
as far as he understood it she was
incapable of disloyalty her fealty to
the clionic dynasty should be above all
else that should be embedded into her
programming and she does counter all of
his points explaining that if kneeling
were against her protocols she wouldn't
have been able to do it at all there
just wouldn't have been a way that she
could have physically so there's tension
there I believe as viewers we're
supposed to wonder about her actual
loyalty just in the same way he is but
they're interrupted as one of of his
aides comes in to tell him that halima's
speech had struck a chord and she's now
the front runner to become the next
Proxima when they go to talk to her we
get a glimpse of some pilgrims who tried
to walk the spiral or maybe some of them
actually completed it but you see that
they get pretty beat up in the process
we find out that demrazel actually did
it she did it many years ago and that
many people die trying to do it he tries
to bargain with the Lima he wants to
know what her ask is what she needs to
back off of calling him Solas and
undermining his authority and her answer
is that she wants him to end the genetic
Dynasty she says it's not a tactic and
that she really does believe that the
dynasty has to end back on the ship
brother day acknowledges that Harry
Selden predicted a split with one of the
major religions essentially that
lumenism would go against the genetic
Dynasty demraisal tries to assert her
loyalty she's ready to play defense and
protect the Empire from halima's mess
message but day has a different plan he
plans to prove Halima and Harry seldom
wrong he goes back to see her and he
declares that he'll appeal to the triple
goddesses themselves who'll walk the
spiral and he'll let them decide what is
true who is right and who is wrong and
that's where his story ends for the
episode and he's set up to do that next
time back at the palace on Tran tour
Brother Don and Azora are escalating
their relationship we see her leave a
message that leads to him finding her
for a rendezvous where they have sex for
the first time she tries to give him a
device that would correct his color
blindness and then he explains why he
would never be able to use that if the
other cleons found out if they noticed
what he was doing then they might notice
all the other ways he's different which
he fires off and there are quite a few
of them to show her just how important
it is that they don't find out he takes
her back to the Palace where he shows
her the original Cleon the first and
then takes her into this back room we
hadn't seen before where they keep
replacement backups for all of them just
in case something happens his reason for
existing the reason that they cloned
them in the first place is for them to
be perfect copies of the original if
they can't do that then they have to be
destroyed and their last day would be
their Replacements first day she tries
to suggest that he should run away and
she has an answer to every reason he
throws out there that he thinks it
wouldn't work she tries to tell him
about where she lives it's called the
scar the area where the star bridge fell
where the lower levels were opened up
and they can actually see outside she
points out how different it is in the
palace and how everything's alive and
it's waiting for him and she really
tries to sell him on it saying that they
can change his face and they can drain
his Nanobots and we'll have to see how
that plays out because I don't know if
any of that will turn out to be possible
or not a little later whenever he misses
the dinner bell brother dust comes
looking for for him where he makes the
excuse that he was trying to learn about
trantor and dust just says we are Tran
tour nothing outside the palace walls is
relevant and their story ends there
and in the final storyline we finally
get back to Gail and what's going on
with Harry on the Raven the Harry Selden
Quantum Consciousness protocol which
eventually stops glitching she's able to
talk to him and he comes back and we
found out that he had a data unit
implanted in his brain before they left
trantor and he finds out that they're on
the Raven heading to Helicon Rach was
supposed to be there Gail was supposed
to be on Terminus to lead the first
foundation and when he finds out that
Lewis is in charge he says that that
would be fine to get them through the
settlement stage but they'll need
someone else for what comes next they'll
be facing the first crisis soon which
we've seen that they are in fact facing
she explains why she's there what
happened that rates has been executed
and for a while he starts glitching out
again and when he leaves this time the
life support systems blink out and so
Gail's running out of oxygen just before
he returns he says that he owes her an
explanation and that his death was an
essential element to the success of the
plan the foundation needs more than a
man to inspire it it needs a myth that
can endure for centuries and it worked
his death galvanized the foundation and
it's no big deal because he was dying
anyway so he took that as an opportunity
to engineer The Narrative alarms start
to sound as they reach the debris field
that surrounds helicon's Dark Star she
knows where they are it's the why she's
struggling with and she wants to know if
Rach knew about everything which he did
Harry was going to take his own life and
Rach would stay around to explain why
then a week or so later he would
disappear and they would reunite on the
Raven because he fell in love with Gail
Harry Nui wouldn't leave her behind and
she gets fed up when she hears this
because he didn't warn her he hasn't
been telling her everything and has been
deciding what she needs to know and it's
pretty rough that he made Rach kill him
so that he would have to leave her she
tries to blame him for for what happened
and he points out that she's too smart
to play the victim they have a pretty
good back and forth he wanted a
different life than the one mapped out
for you and you made a choice to lie to
the emperor they agreed that they're
both Hypocrites as she points out if it
were really just about the path that
psycho history laid out Harry would have
let Cleon kill him in the throne room
everything still would have fallen into
place as they continued to debate who's
responsible for Rachel's death Harry
starts to push for an answer about why
she was in his room the night he died in
the first place that leads into a
sequence with her trying to explain and
reminding us of all the different times
she had feelings or knew something would
happen and then she turns towards the
view screen at the exact moment she
needs to to stop a micro meteor right as
it breaches the ship's Hull they
realized that Harry couldn't predict
that she was going to be there because
whatever gives her this ability is
beyond normal human behavior she's
different and she describes it saying
that she thinks she can feel the future
as the episode comes to an end
getting close
before we catch up with what's happening
on the Invictus there's a flashback to
nacrion where we see a young pharah
experiencing the planetary attack Salvo
was able to pull these details whenever
she was reading pharah earlier in the
season and here pharah says that after
they were gone talking about the
Empire's ships there were no children
left only Warriors and I guess it does a
good job to set up why Pharaoh is the
way she is how all consuming her desire
for revenge is even when salvor makes
some great points about how terrible her
plan to jump the Invictus into the
center of the planet trantor is it would
kill everyone on the capital Planet but
her people and everyone else in the
outer reach would be on the hook for
that and while the Empire wouldn't let
something like that go the threat for
salver is that if she doesn't help them
then all those Hunters that were left
behind will kill everyone on Terminus
starting with her mother there's still a
ticking clock situation until the next
jump most of the scientists they brought
with them are dead when they finally
disabled the defenses salvor opens the
door and she finds a gun on the ground
she fires it at pharah and is able to
get inside alone with Lewis there they
put together what was happening with the
crew they find out that the captain
killed herself there and when they find
the navigation cradle we get a little
bit of background in history into how
jump ships evolved this is from a time
before they had spacers so everyone on
board had to sedate themselves before a
jump and we get an explanation that
folding space was as much intuition as
it was science and the bottom line here
is that what needs to happen is someone
needs to connect their brain to the
navigation AI to guide the ship
somewhere safe or it'll continue making
random jumps problem is this is a death
sentence since there isn't time to do
the necessary surgery and because salvor
sees herself as an outlier she
volunteers and says that she wants to
guide the ship to terminus as that's all
playing out we see that Hugo did find
his way to a Communications relay he's
not dead he rerouted himself to one of
the mine sites he turns it on and he
sends out an SOS to the thespins on the
planet salvor's mother says they need to
evacuate term in a city because the null
field around the vault is continuing to
expand and she thinks it's going to
overtake them all which is a tough thing
to sell to the inacrions in charge
because they'd have to take the fence
down when we get back inside the ship
there's just five minutes left Farah and
Rowan are still outside trying to break
in and salvor is trying to talk Lewis
into hooking her up to the navigation
here we see her thinking change because
of her Visions she had thought that she
was there for a reason and now she
thinks this is it she's meant to
sacrifice her life to get this ship to
terminus but before Lewis can hook her
up to the navigation he gets shot by
pharaoh a fight breaks out between her
and salvor and then we see the thespians
show up but they turn out to be too late
and the ship Begins the jump and
disappears so that's our Cliffhanger is
where will it end up based on what we
learned in this scene they may find
themselves somewhere pretty far away
from the action going on on terminus
with brother day we see that he's
committed himself to a pretty serious
Risk by agreeing to do the spiral he has
to give up his protective Aura and have
his Imperial Nanobots removed and he has
to take this Trek with no food no water
and no rest where for the first time in
his life he's going to be subject to
injury less than half of the people who
start this trip make it to the center if
they do the goal is to make it to a cave
in the center called the mother's womb
that has a pool of water inside there's
special salt around it and after you
submerge yourself in the pool if the
mother is willing you'll see a vision
each one of these is unique and deeply
personal and a group of Zephyrs will
interpret what it means it's an
interesting situation it's not just
physically difficult if he doesn't make
it that would give Halima a huge
advantage in her arguments against the
Dynasty and we see the trip as a
struggle after he gets pretty far into
it he meets another man they have a
conversation where we learn a little bit
about regular other people in the Empire
people who live outside of Tran tour and
at one point when brother day drops to
one knee after injuring his foot this
person tells him not to give up and
helps him up later the tables are turned
the man drops and when day reaches out
to help him he says that the mother is
calling and submits by dropping to his
second knee when day tries to at least
help him off the path where he'll be
able to get help he refuses as he wants
to die right there rather than being
saved he explains that a peaceful
transition to a Holier life is the
mother's greatest gift and because the
emperor doesn't have any faith in this
religion he tries to get him to change
his mind he says what if there is no
other life what if this is just the end
the man just lays on the ground and says
maybe we'll meet again you can tell me
what you saw and Cleon has to continue
the struggle on his own he finally makes
it to the cave and he finds the pool we
see him laugh with joy as he gets into
the water and it looks like he is is
experiencing Wonder as we watch him
splash the water over his sunburnt body
and drinking it all in that cuts to him
in front of the three Zephyrs where he
explains what he saw he said the salt
started to move and it began to swirl
lifting off the floor of the cave it
formed a stem in three petals and as
he's talking we see that Halima looks
worried the three Zephyrs the
representations of the mother maiden and
Crone talk to each other and then ask if
he's familiar with the mythology around
the birth root flower and he says he's
not they explain its significance how
whenever the three moons were created
the maiden was covered in a blanket of
birth roots and it was a sign from the
triple goddess that their world could
sustain life over the centuries the
flowers died off and they haven't been
seen for thousands of years they
interpret this as a holy sign three
elements made out of one and he says
just like my brothers and I to which
they respond just like the triple
goddesses at the end they're convinced
that he's clearly not a soul mired in
stagnation and anyone who says that will
be guilty of sin themselves from this
day forward no other Zephyr will stand
in the way of the genetic Dynasty so
essentially he's won everyone bows even
Halima later on the way back to his ship
he thanks sir for inspiring him to
attempt a spiral and then demersell goes
to see her in her room she starts by
saying that she wants to extend her
condolences and then they have a
conversation where she admits that she
can't go against the emperor she can't
leave her role at his side and then
explains it was 11 000 years ago when
she walked the spiral which is basically
her admitting that she's a robot Halima
had heard these rumors I guess they're
out there in the Empire that the last
humaniform robot in the Galaxy does
assist the Dynasty and demrazel explains
that like Empire she doesn't have
individuated sentience she must not be
in possession of a soul either there
because if she were she would be able to
disobey his commands and it's clear at
this point that she was sent there to
kill her we see that she's visibly
struggling and Halima picks up on this
saying that she sees genuine remorse she
doesn't know how she can tell but she
knows that demarzel has a soul on the
other hand the person that's making her
do these things is truly a soulless man
she forgives her and tells her to do
what she must after all she's going to
be reincarnated according to her faith
she's already been poisoned through a
secretion when their skin touched and
after assuring her that she'll feel no
pain demraisal leaves she goes back and
tells Cleon and assures him that it'll
look like she died of natural causes
then she asks him if he saw the ancient
birth root flower on her desk which is
basically an accusation she's throwing
it out there that she wonders if he made
his vision up she explains that when she
did it she had a real vision and that
she would not wish that emptiness of
seeing nothing on anyone and it really
is an intense showdown between these two
characters as the spacers are preparing
him for the jump we get confirmation
that he didn't have a vision at all that
he was just there and what demerzel
implied was true which is a pretty big
Revelation and I will come back to this
at the end
from there we go back to the Raven and
we hear Harry asked Gail how long she's
been able to feel the future it's been
happening as long as she can remember
and most of the time it's just a feeling
like what happened with the micro meteor
but other times it comes in dreams Harry
says that a dream drove her to
mathematics and that proves that it
wasn't a dream at all but a premonition
he thinks she might have some intuitive
processing ability that would put her
ahead of the math because that would
explain how she was able to solve a
Praxis she wants to know why they're
going to Helicon and he still thinks he
needs to keep her in the dark because
this prescience of hers has the
potential to skew psycho history
completely after all look what happened
with Rach she's there and he's not and
this creates a big problem between them
the most he'll give her is that
Mankind's survival is predicated on us
reaching Helicon and when she pushes
saying that she thought it depended on
the foundation he explains that it does
to an extent but only if its sister
organization is a established as well so
there is a second Foundation that needs
to be created at Star's end on Helicon
Terminus was created by an imperial
Charter and was designed in part to draw
fire but the second foundation and its
location must be kept secret even from
the first and things escalate from there
because she continues to ask questions
and he refuses to answer other than
saying that he has allies and resources
on Helicon where they could safely study
her gifts and possibly use them to their
advantage she says that her instincts
are telling her to leave the same way
that she came and he points out the fact
that it would take her decades to get to
terminus she wouldn't even be able to go
to trantor and that her best bet is to
stay on the Raven it all boils down to
her giving Harry an ultimatum tell her
everything or she'll destroy the heat
transfer system which will cause her to
die if she stays on the ship he says he
can't possibly do that he can't
jeopardize the second found Foundation
before it even gets started and when she
follows through when she destroys the
system he has the choice of either
letting her die on the ship or letting
her leave eventually he does and we see
her walk through the door she takes the
knife out of the lock and gets back into
the cryopod and when she asks the
navigation how long it'll take to get to
synax we find out that it's 138 years as
she confirms the destination so she's
going back to sleep headed towards a
dead Planet as far as we know at that
point and that should effectively put
her out of the story for over a century
as I mentioned at the beginning it is
good to get some reveals people who'd
read the books knew that there was going
to be a reveal at some point about a
second Foundation but even having that
idea going into it Gail leaving here is
a pretty big twist I won't get into the
spoilers of why that is because we don't
really know what's going to happen in
the next two episodes but what's
important here is that there's a second
Foundation who are kept secret to help
guide thing and it was always part of
Harry's plan and I hope we learn a lot
more about it in the upcoming episodes
no choice in any of this
thank you
so we'll start with brother dawn he
doesn't want to be killed and replaced
so he's meeting and planning with Azora
to get out of there and we learned that
he's planning on leaving tomorrow and
that he'll need a signal damper for the
Nanobots in his bloodstream he gets
summoned to meet with dusk at the mural
they talk about how it captures their
legacy he mentions some of the different
scenes including the end of the robot
wars the golden horse rebellion and the
attack on anacrion and thespus that we
saw in the opening episodes he's brought
him there because he's added their hunt
to the mural and he's done this as a
setup to test him to see if he's
colorblind he asks if he can see the
three Gilly Raptors that he shot and
since he can only see the blue ones he
says yes after dusk leaves he uses the
corrected device that Azure gave him and
he realizes that are six and now he's
sure that dusk knows he's different he
rushes in to pack a bag and leave but
before he can get out of there Shadow
Mass Mr obrecht comes in saying that
brother dusk needs to see him right away
he tries unsuccessfully to talk his way
out of it and then he has to use his
Aura which also has a weapon mechanism
to knock out the shadow master and then
escapes to the garden and this escape
sequence it seemed a little bit funny
whenever I watched it the first time I
guess it all makes sense in the end that
they were letting him go because it felt
kind of hard to believe that he was able
to get out at all he does though he has
this dramatic sequence that involves
this water reservoir and he makes his
way outside the palace he's on his own
he's freezing and he trades the only
thing he has of value which is his Aura
to one of the people that lives down
there for his jacket from there he's
able to make his way to the scar azora's
neighborhood by remembering what she
told him about it and he eventually
finds where she lives she welcomes him
and tells him not to worry that she's
installed the signal damper so he
doesn't have to worry about being found
until tells him to take a shower after
he goes in he has an idea about the new
name that he's going to take and he
comes back out to find her with a gun in
her hand and she takes a shot he's able
to get outside of the apartment but he's
pursued by a group of goons and then
he's captured by himself he looks up to
see someone that looks exactly like him
when he wakes up he sees that his
Imperial Nanobots are being transferred
to a different clone who was raised
outside the palace he explains to him
that someone was able to smuggle some of
cleons DNA out and they've been working
on this plan for decades it's a
coordinated effort Azora was part of it
and it seems like someone powerful would
have to be behind it because they're
playing a long game here and they have
access he explains all this with a
British accent so you can tell them
apart which is kind of funny but he
shows him that he's been practicing that
he can copy him exactly and the plan is
for him to replace the original Dawn
they altered his DNA after the fact so
that he would become different and the
replacement is an exact copy the reason
that they altered the DNA was because
they needed to get him out of the palace
they wanted to orchestrate a reason for
him to run on his own fearing for his
own Survival and when the nanobot
transfer is complete we see that the new
clone heals immediately so now he's
basically just a normal person and has
outlived his usefulness
but as I mentioned earlier they let Dawn
get away so they could follow him to
these people and so dusk in the shadow
master and a group of soldiers swoop in
for a rescue faked on is killed Shadow
Master obrecht uses that cloaking device
that we saw earlier in the season to
sneak up behind and cut his throat Azora
has taken prisoners so they can
interrogate her and thus says that he
wants a memory audit done on all of the
dead people in the room after they lead
Azora away dusk explains that they would
be able to overlook that but the matter
of his difference is rather more
complicated dawn looks at it like he's a
victim there was a conspiracy and it's
not his fault that he's been altered but
I mean come on that's why they have the
backups this has been his dilemma the
whole time he's a reminder of their
vulnerability and thus basically says
what logic is there to keep him around
Brother Don pleads for him to forget
logic and try empathy and in the end
it's not up to dusk anyways it's up to
brother day and he'll be back soon and I
suppose that it'll boil down to how he's
feeling after his Showdown with the
luminists on the foundation side of
things we see a flashback to a young
salvoir talking to her dad she asked
them where they came from and they talk
about the origins of humanity humans are
thought to have inhabited a single
system but they don't remember which
anymore he throws out the idea of series
Alpha Centauri and says that some people
think we came from some place called
Earth all of this is leading to
questions about anacrion's Investments
too how they're all humans and they all
came from the same place so then how
come they hate them so much her father
tells her that rational thinking shares
skull space with our emotions and
sometimes the emotions went out millions
of people died when the star Bridge came
down and then the empire killed Millions
more and who won and he brings out that
trademark phrase violence is the last
Refuge of the incompetent and he's using
all of this to make the point that this
is how they know the Empire's gonna fall
past behavior is the best predictor of
future performance Salvo was able to
stay awake for the jump just as Gail was
able to when she traveled to trantor
from synax it turns out that they did
make it back to terminus because Lewis
connected himself to the navigation and
got them there after he was shot and of
course he didn't survive since she's the
only one that's awake and she can't get
a hold of anyone on Terminus she ends up
leaving the Invictus doing a spacewalk
to get back to her ship while she's
there she reunites with Hugo and they
realize the null field is probably why
they can't reach anyone on the planet he
makes a suggestion that they just run
away from it all but she says that she
needs to fix this and so he goes back to
the Invictus and because she's immune to
the null field she heads towards the
planet on the surface it turns out they
were right everyone's knocked out and so
salvor heads to the Vault there she
finds her mother passed out with the
prime radiant in her hand she takes that
and she concentrates and through
memories actually Gail's memories she
remembers how to open it and when she
does the Vault reacts it opens and the
null field is lifted people are starting
to wake up on the Invictus when Hugo and
the thespians arrived they couldn't find
pharah it turns out she's boarding one
of those thespian lancers and takes
control of it and at this point
everyone's heading towards the surface
salvor moves towards the Vault and her
mother tries to stop her but then the
anacrion spiral warning shot that's
followed by the thespian ships arriving
everyone on board starts to come out and
these ships have this thing where the
captain can remotely control the fire
power and so that's enough to get the
anacrions to stand down
salvor believes this is where she's
supposed to be she sees everything
converging in a single crisis and things
get more intense when pharah arrives in
that Lancer and destroys the other ones
that were already there she has the same
remote control device for the ship so
that gets the thespians to stand down
and she wants to kill salvor who tries
to convince her that the Invictus is the
most powerful ship that they'll ever get
their hands on so why destroy it why not
use it for leverage she makes the
suggestion that they all band together
and then she draws off her father's
words saying let our logic speak louder
than our emotions Pharaoh's soldiers are
receptive to this and Rowan tells her
that the Hunt is over then something
like a bolt of lightning shoots out of
the Vault and pharah decides that
shooting it with her ship seems like the
best course of action this isn't
something that salvor can let happen so
she uses the grand huntress's bow to
kill her which increases tensions with
every everyone but then they're all
taken aback when Harry Selden walks out
of the Vault he says well this is
encouraging and nacrion's thespins and
Termini seeing you all gathered here
gives me hope we might actually pull
this off and the episode ends there
history
we are Empire
history binge to us
I am loyal Empire
to the clionic dynasty Above All Else
episode 9 ended with the death of pharah
in the midst of the conflict between the
different factions of the outer reach
taking place on Terminus Harry Selden
emerged From the Vault and he seemed
alright with what was happening in the
finale we get a better understanding of
how he came to be there and what it all
means for psycho history in the
foundation he's a projection and he
explains to Paulie who asked him if he
was the ghost that he took a pill that
contained millions of self-replicating
molecular machines those broke his body
down inside the coffin that he had made
and it recycled that material
transforming into the Vault on its way
to terminus so the vault is actually
made of him but over those decades he
wasn't awake he wasn't sentient that
whole time he explains that his
Reawakening was triggered by the
inacrion's arrival he says that it takes
time to rebuild Consciousness and when
salvor tries to connect things to the
null field EXP ending he explains that
it's just part of the vault's natural
defenses Harry addresses the anacrines
in thespians saying that they've hated
each other for so long that the origin
of their Feud is almost irrelevant and
he explains that the first clone Cleon
II is responsible for setting things in
motion the generations of hate between
these two cultures that we saw was
ongoing in episode 1 when they came to
trantor all traces back to What's called
the first betrayal where Cleon II had
his shadow Master murder and anachron
Grand Huntress and blame it on the
thespian King she just married the point
was that this marriage was going to
bring together these two emerging powers
in the outer reach and that would be a
threat to the Empire's power so the
emperor decided to undermine that
knowing that it would get them to fight
each other and then he wouldn't have to
deal with it now Harry says he needs
them to put that behind them and come
together he selected the original
colonists on Terminus to have the seeds
of a future civilization and the others
are survivors they've been cast aside by
the Empire and they're still there under
the genetic Dynasty there's only room
for one story and one voice and he
believes that that stagnation guarantees
that the Empire will fall and that will
be followed by a dark age that lasts
thirty thousand years it was always part
of his plan for these three cultures in
the outer reach to come together he
explains that he found the pattern in
the jumps of the Invictus and that
they're discovering it would be a
potential step ahead for the
foundation's development he explains
that the idea of them curating knowledge
for the encyclopedia was only a cover
Story the foundation was never about
that it was about curating people and
when one of the foundationers Echoes
what he says about them not being
revolutionaries he says that he may have
lied about that point there's still a
problem in that the Empire is still
going to come investigate what happened
to Darwin's ship who was there in the
first place to investigate what happened
to the comms buoy Harry tells them that
they won't come if they think they're
already dead and he tells them to use
the Invictus to create a false Mega
Flare something like that would wipe out
all life in the system and therefore
there would be no reason for them to
come into a situation where there might
be a dangerous star and a bunch of dead
planets even if it did host the
foundation at one time after that if
they don't leave the outer reach they
would be invisible and more importantly
they would be free they can bide their
time build up their strengths and become
what they need to be to shorten that
period of Darkness according to Psycho
history
as he gets ready to return to the Vault
they ask if they'll see him again he
expects that to be the case because this
isn't the foundation's first crisis and
it won't be the last they bought
themselves some time but war with Empire
is inevitable he tells them to remember
this day remember what they're striving
for and remember that a thousand years
can seem like a long time but it's only
a blip on the history of civilization
and if they're not Vigilant this
opportunity that they have could slip
right through their fingers as he was
talking he realized Gail wasn't there
and that she never made it to terminus
in that exchange he meets salvor but
it's clear that he didn't anticipate her
or know who she was so as he's leaving
she asks him about the visions that
she's been having and he doesn't know
what she's talking about she explains
that she used them to help her solve the
crisis and he assures her that divisions
didn't come from him and then the
projection goes back inside the Vault
and it closes up and it looks like it
did before beforehand so what does it
mean for the foundation we see that the
cultures are willing to work together
there's an exchange where Rowan gives
the grand huntress's bow to salvor in an
act of peace and they plant a sapling
from an Acron together at the site of
pharah's burial Mari and the other
foundationers are angry they feel
betrayed and it's not so much that Harry
didn't tell them what was going to
happen but that he lied to them salvor's
in a similar situation she grew up
thinking that the ghost was talking to
her that Harry Selden was talking to her
through the Vault she started to believe
that she was special and now she has no
idea where the Visions were coming from
there's a time lapse of the colony
growing over the next few months
everyone has come together and they're
taking Harry's words to Heart setting
aside their hatred and favor of strength
and moving forward with the foundation
they repair the Invictus and Hugo
becomes the captain he goes out and
generates the Mega Flare allowing them
to be free and now that they have the
technology we learn that it'll take them
about 18 months until they can start
building new ships for her crucial role
in the crisis salvor is set to become
the next mayor but she has another
Vision where she sees a young gailed she
goes to see her mother asking her about
who the girl from the water planet was
this leads to the big reveal that Gail
and Rach were her biological parents and
the Visions were related to their
memories rather than Harry she knows
that Gail escaped the slow ship in a
cryopod and decides that she needs to
leave Terminus and go look for her she
decides she wants to leave right away
because she's afraid that she'll change
her mind and her mother gives her her
blessing and the prime radiant to take
with her she goes to the beggar and Hugo
finds her before she leaves they have
their goodbye and we get an
understanding of where her head's at she
thinks this is something that she needs
to do alone and when he asks where she's
going she just says that she has a hunch
and she leaves as has often been the
case in this first season where things
get really inner interesting is on Tran
tour and what happened to Azora brother
dawn and the conspiracy brother day has
returned to the planet and his trip to
the maiden has changed his thinking
brother dusk wants to destroy Dawn and
replace him and when day goes to talk to
him he says you're not one of us your
DNA has been altered in a dozen ways he
wants to know how long he's known and
this brings about a really interesting
conversation about how they aren't even
really people they're just Echoes of the
first clion and hasn't day himself ever
wanted to leave this place be something
more than just an installment in this
ongoing story
when he goes to speak with Azora he
explains that he understands that people
hate him but says that his Detachment
from them is what makes it possible for
him to rule effectively it's a strange
burden not being able to carry a burden
the brothers care for each other they
love each other and they shift that
burden between each other he views Dawn
as his son he rocked him as a baby he
cultivated him and Azora took all of
that away from him so he wants to take
away her Legacy and they located every
person family friends lovers and so on
anyone that would remember her after she
was gone it's a total of 1551 people
they have them all under surveillance
and there's a particle being focused on
their brain stem so that when he gives
the signal they'll all be killed and
right after he explains this he gives
the signal so they're all dead he then
tells her what her fate will be she'll
be put into automated extreme isolation
where she'll be sensory shrouded but
she'll still be a aware and he's doing
that so that she can remember what she
took from him and it's a brutal fate no
matter how you look at it demrazelle
comes to Dawn she tells him it's time
and on their walk to the throne room he
says that she must hate him she assures
him that's not the case she actually
loves him and when he says that it's
only because she's programmed too she
explains that all love is programmed
biological or otherwise saying that when
a human mother looks at her child their
brain waves synchronize when he's
brought before duskin day it's clear
that dusk hasn't changed his mind at all
but he has to default to the middle
Throne brother day explains on his trip
he had much time to reflect on their
Dynasty he talks about the pilgrims he
met who worked their whole lives just to
walk a spiral of salt in hopes that they
might be granted a vision before they
die he talks about The Challenge from
Halima he brings up Harry Selden how he
prophesies something similar and
declares that a bowel and capable of
bending will eventually break he says
it's time to die Dynasty bent just a
little brother dusk is not willing to go
along with this and they start fighting
he's convinced that it'll ruin their
Dynasty and he threatens to decant
another day rather than allowing the
altered Dawn to live as they continue to
fight Dawn goes to demerzel for
protection and she holds him like a
child stroking his hair brother dust
shouts we are Empire history bends to us
and as he's saying that demersell snaps
brother Dawn's neck killing him
instantly when brother Day protests
yelling no she tells him that she's
loyal to the clionic dynasty above all
else after he disintegrates the body the
shadow Master comes to him to say that
the rebels plans to undermine the
dynasty appear to be more extensive than
they first believed they thought the
gene editing was limited entirely to
brother Dawn's person in that it was
done after he was incarnated which is
what the other clone told him whenever
he was in the scar after more testing
though they found that the source itself
was adulterated as were The Replacements
those are no longer pure copies so the
source material is gone brother dawn is
dead and they can't replace him with
another pure clone even day himself
could be altered they don't know that
yet as well as brother dusk who's being
tested right at that moment he sends the
shadow Master away and in a rage he
smashes the glass case containing the
original Cleon the first then demerzel
goes back to her room takes off her salt
bracelet and looks in the mirror she
looks troubled she opens her kit and
grabs a tool before tossing it aside and
then tears her face off as she screams
and with a lot of unanswered questions
about the future the Tran tour storyline
ends there so what happened with Gail
and salvor Hardin well we get one last
scene that takes place 138 years later
we see Gail arrive on cinex she's able
to find her home there's no signs of
Life there anymore maybe not any on the
planet at all as we see that the water
is much higher as she's mourning she
sees a light under the water and decides
to go find out what it is it turns out
to be the beggar and inside she finds
salvor in a cryopod she gets her out of
the water and wakes her up and when she
asked her what happened she explains
that she crashed landed she's been in
Christ asleep for more than a century
and says that she was there looking for
someone which of course she was looking
for Gail and she tells her I'm salvor
hardened your daughter and then she
hands her the prime radiant and the
episode ends there
so in the end where are we at the
foundation survived the first crisis and
came out of it with an alliance in the
outer reach that will make them stronger
one version of Harry selden's
Consciousness exists inside the Vault to
be a reassuring Presence at the very
least the initial reason he got the
encyclopedist Exile determinus was a lie
but things appear to be on course for
the plan and psycho history should serve
its purpose to shorten the Dark Age that
will come after the fall of the Galactic
Empire periodic crises are baked into
that and Harry should re-emerge
accordingly Galen salvor are mother and
daughter and they have these unique
abilities they don't quite understand
they're together but their future is
uncertain considering they have the
prime radiant I have some ideas based on
what I know from reading the books but I
won't go into those here they're being
on synex means that they're somewhat
isolated but considering the foundation
has at least one jump ship now they
could be connected without another
prolonged period of cryosleep either way
enough time has passed that things are
completely different on Terminus and
it's going to take time for that story
to catch up to where they're at the
clionic dynasty also has an uncertain
future the only thing that seems certain
is that it won't be carrying on like it
has for the last 400 years they left
things pretty wide open as far as
whether brother Dusk and brother day
were altered and there really wasn't any
progress as far as finding out who's
behind the conspiracy demersell's final
scene was fascinating and I think one of
my next videos will be talking about
what I think is going on there for now
it appears that Cleon the first altered
her programming to be loyal to the
clionic dynasty Above All Else and the
things that she has to do in relation to
that are taking a toll on her it'll be
interesting to see how she responds to
the Dilemma of having no new clones or
pure genetic material to continue the
dynasty as they've known it for a review
this first season had its issues
especially in the structure and pacing
of the Early Middle episodes overall the
terminate storyline was noticeably
weaker than the story with the cleons
and there were places where it just
didn't work for me I'm sure some of that
can be chalked up to the pandemic but it
also felt to me that they defaulted to
try to do a cool action thing in a lot
of situations with mixed results I do
give them credit for the effort though
looking back they did a lot of crazy
things and I think generally speaking
it's always good to see a show that
takes chances and I'm hoping that
they'll be able to identify what worked
and what didn't and come back with a
much stronger effort in the second
season there was a lot of effort to
develop the characters and again I think
this worked a whole lot better on the
Tran tour side of things but as far as
the finales concerned it felt like a
step up across the board in that
department so at least it feels like
they're going in the right direction
there even with having so many different
stories that all felt somewhat different
to tie up in one hour long episode from
Asimov they've got a toolbox to pull
from that includes some great twists and
turns based on psycho history and the
part they introduced themselves the
genetic Dynasty has turned out to be a
great addition they managed to pull off
some great sci-fi and character stuff at
the same time there's so much rolled up
in that Dynamic and I love the
progression of brother day through his
trip than coming back to his
interactions with Dusk and Dawn and
Azora respectively only to be completely
invested in what was going on in his
decision and then actually shocked at
what demerzel did the thought of brother
day being on the verge of changing
things only to have it snatched away by
a Fail-Safe that we have to assume was
instituted by the original Cleon that
was the highlight of the season the most
powerful person in the galaxy is trapped
in that cycle there's really nothing
they can can do to change things and now
there's no way to continue that so even
with the issues it had I'm pretty happy
with where we're at I'm curious to see
where they go from here and I'm glad I
watched it and I'm happy that they made
it it was ambitious and sprawling and
you can't take that away from it this
thing was huge in scope and budget it
was a proper spectacle at times and
there's a lot to like there if you go
looking for it and I think that's a good
place to leave things I do have a lot of
questions though and I'll be following
this up with a season two questions
video sometime during this week so let
me know what questions you have for that
in the comments and let me know what you
thought of the Season what you thought
of the finale and if you want to talk
book spoilers just make sure you mark
them please like this video If you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon